uh let's go next to Aiden from Alberta
Aiden welcome to the program
Aiden from Alberta
Aiden I'm guessing you have the wrong
audio device selected hello hello oh I
think I got it you got okay I'll make it
quick since I wasted all the time there
please so Charlie Christ very good last
night in my opinion oh yeah um and one
of the things I noticed is uh he used
some common Republican talking points
against DeSantis yeah specifically the
rep the uh gas prices I noticed he
attacked DeSantis on the gas prices
thing yeah which uh I was wondering if
you think democrats should do that more
using those more kind of political
arguments that the Republicans use
against themselves listen I am not going
to tell anybody
to stop using whatever works
against terrible people like Ron
DeSantis so if Charlie Crist saying
listen you want to talk about the Biden
gas prices
it's the DeSantis gas prices they're off
the charts here in Florida
if that works use it you know there's
nothing immoral about that you're not
shooting anyone you're not defrauding
anyone you're just really
strategically choosing who to blame for
something that's really a national
phenomenon in my heart of hearts I don't
think Biden nor DeSantis have much to do
with gas prices as I've said before but
it's the type of thing where I would say
if it works absolutely do it
yeah no I completely agree and uh yeah
thank you have a have a good rest of
your show today all right Aiden from
Alberta great to hear from you let's go
next to Jasper from Brazil Jasper
welcome
hi David how's it going it's going well
so I wanted to ask you
um I see countries like Argentina and
Brazil where I'm currently living trying
these same sorts of protectionist uh
trade strategies over and over again
particularly when led by populist
leftist leaders and they often don't
work to grow the local economy of the
opposite effect to sink the local
currency do you think the left has some
sort of populist trade policy problem
um so when it comes to populism
I don't see populism really as being
policy I see populism as being a
rhetoric and a messaging strategy so
I would not say that there's a left
populism trade policy problem because I
don't think populism by definition is
policy now as applied to Argentina
specifically
it's been one disastrous decision after
another after another by every
Administration it's been Christina
Alberto macri it's it's been just
disastrous all the way down
and
it is also true that the current debt
situation which is absolutely related to
the IMF and World Bank history with
Argentina
and we can't say that there is no
responsibility or blame there is also
completely untenable that I don't know
that you're even going to trade your way
out of the problem anyway so anybody who
like the thing that will happen is
depending on which Hammer you have or
maybe better said depending on whether
you have a hammer or a drill you see
everything as either a nail or a screw
in terms of saying the problem has been
Christina and Alberto and others say no
no no no no the problem has been Makati
no no no the problem has been the IMF it
is Decades of bad decisions upon Bad
Decisions by bad leaders
and there's no one thing to blame but no
I don't think it's a populism policy
problem since populism isn't really a
policy it's a rhetoric
okay thanks may I also ask you another
question about uh bolsonaro the election
is coming up on I believe Saturday yeah
Sunday isn't it or is it Saturday no
it's a Sunday
okay Sunday uh
yeah and he seems pretty dangerous and
it it looks like he has a very good
chance to win
what do you think could happen in the
next sort of four years here in Brazil
I would defer to the real experts on
Brazilian politics I agree with you he
clearly has a shot to win but uh I I
would ask someone who is following the
Brazilian situation more closely it it
doesn't make sense for me to be the
person opining on that
okay fair thank you all right my
pleasure there is Jasper from Brazil
with a very very interesting question